hey everybody what's going on welcome to
stream Coco's one-day ballet we're back
we're back don't grow up it's a trap I'm
wearing this because the Star Wars
trailer is going to be tonight on Monday
Night Football so there we go this is my
Star Wars II assert I've got today I was
in Armenia all last week which is great
shooting a show helping shoot a show
actually just do behind-the-scenes stuff
for the web but I like to put myself on
board with the show so and it was a
crazy trip we were out in another
country so I thought today we could play
a little uncharted right I've never
played Uncharted we are gonna be playing
from the Nathan Drake collection I know
it sounds like Oh what are you wearing
oh it's from the Nathan Drake collection
smells like sweat and blood and
adventure the Nathan Drake collection so
welcome everybody yeah yeah seven joy
joy I get to see you such a beautiful
lie what light would be beautiful by the
way such a beautiful lie what kind of
lie is that deejay mom jeans what's up
and miss prime stingray and Bolivia
Smith's awesome
I've never played these games but I hear
they're effing amazing so let's get into
it
continue a speedrun I love that that's
an option I love it but we're not going
to do that we're gonna play the campaign
and we're gonna play it on crushing no
we try not crushing I've never played
this i play it i crushing hey hey what's
up by Deb in public Eddie what's up
piece of tofu Cassie hey ho life is such
a beautiful lie ooh I think that because
you're talking about the matrix right
we're talking about the being inside the
matrix life is a lie
what are we alright fine normal it is
normal it is we're not gonna do crushing
you clearly know my skills at work guys
a quick very quick announcement well
they're gonna be going in till 1:00 p.m.
today just for an hour because this
Thursday we've got a very special stream
Koko event
this Thursday at 3:30 p.m. Pacific we're
gonna welcome two-time WWE Divas
Champion Paige she's only known as Paige
it's like Madonna like Paige who's gonna
be bringing the WWE 2k16 preview for us
to play and that doesn't come on until
10:00 27 so we're very very excited
tuned in right here on YouTube and
twitch that TV to see Paige and I
streaming live and you are you excited
are you a huge wrestling fan yes up top
so cool those guys do this guy's a huge
douche that's right physicists can we
see Paige put Beth into a sexy leg lock
I don't think so oh no maybe I should
arm wrestle hey maybe I should arm
wrestle Paige I think she just storing
you though I feel like Paige is an
awesome shape and I'm not keep her went
of wind what's up John Cena not coming
on Thursday Paige is coming because
she's gonna be on the show on Thursday
yes that's why she's gonna be it's not a
random thing
whoo
love this guy whoo who would play Drake
this guy's Drake right yeah this is what
confusing to me I think it's like false
advertising people I keep expecting he
thinks very he looks very Nathan Fillion
right yes we're very yeah I'm expecting
like you know like ain't no talent like
a little like you know like hold on but
going home little oh we got some
problems Jake the snake Roberts Nathan
Fillion hands down xbox die kid says
Randy Orton yeah yeah Oh Bradley Cooper
yeah Bradley Cooper I feel like it even
sounds like they him fill you though
this is very yes stop this violence get
Paige to bring John Cena so he can break
my arm and sign my arm casteth Paige
keep her wind I think you might have a
little skewed priorities whoa right
brain and the brain sack whoa
we going here we're oh geez
yeah I'll just shoot him in the dick I'm
a dick shooter I've said it before I'll
say it again
Yeah right Neal crotch arewe whoa
let's see a fast and furious combo oh
yeah oh yeah this is great
whoa whoa whoa should I be barefoot I
feel like that's bad I mean today we're
today we're playing it we're not going
to finish it I mean this game already is
awesome I'm loving it like McDonald's
ooh for a brutal combo
oh-ho super punch what happened there
another guy no Beth didn't go because
she went in my heart yes what did I
bring back for everybody from Armenia
way got everybody metal it's right
Russian war medals in World War two a
lot of people don't realize this but
Armenia was under Soviet rule for like
70 years and I had a lot of very hard
work but it was very fun we did a lot of
great stuff I think we got a lot of good
footage I'm excited for me to see the
show as soon as I kill these mofos I saw
an as you get hurt things go more black
and white so it turns more into an art
film as you get hurt
I said that this whole series of motion
capture whoa really Wow
she Zeus my god how do we destroy this
thing chrono you're totally wrong John
seen it would kick my ass seven ways
from Sunday
here we go there we go see flame
oh no wait what now the boats on fire
this is crazy
yeah well you Bob all that's what's
gonna be it'll be
is this our place this guy a good guy
what's going on hi by the way if I had a
plane I think it would be you on the fat
bet it would be you you'd be like with a
laptop would it be real yeah you know a
deal you know like on the front like how
they all have like sexy pinup models but
it'd be just this exactly this you'd
feel like this well I'd like a nice
smile like this like ideally do like to
think do it um this is what it'd be like
on the front of my plane I love the
voice acting in this thank goodness we
were wearing our wet suits already with
such a beautiful us as this game has
been major influential because of its
motion capture use whoa we should play
j-stars victory vs next week I don't
know what that is chicken God one
hurts you from the coffee errant I'll
let the creep factor they quickly dialed
it down again I punched up and punched
it down it's like I don't dial I don't
use this I use the buttons this feels
very much like an Indiana Jones it feels
very much like they uh-oh they are
making a movie who's gonna be it Nathan
Fillion this is great I should be
playing Halo 5 next week don't tell me
how to live how about that next time I
have played Assassin's Creed it's great
you know the veteran Uncharted
journalist who played this game in Tokyo
and said look great but too familiar
wait the veteran Uncharted journalist I
don't you're saying yeah it's new
Indiana Jones yes hashtag dick shots I
love that korva stuff he's wearing like
what did this get this game came out in
like the mid-2000s right so I guess that
was cool back then I guess oh look at
the look of the day cuz he was wearing a
wedding ring around his neck is Nathan
Drake are you know who else could play
Nathan Drake like the guy in Friday
Night Lights oh yeah I Cal Chandler he's
got a very Chandler hair yes I will I'm
very excited
what's up shaggy taco good to see you
I'm not sure I would eat a shaggy taco
though shaggy tacos sounds a little
gross it's a sex ring no one says that
front tuck oh it's sir Oh such beautiful
asses at Sir Francis Drake's ring
now here's what I don't know who was
super ancestry
what do you what did he find did he find
and just Drake only rap about Sir
Francis Drake's accomplishments because
that would be great
well you saw Hamilton last week speaking
of raps Hamilton if you're in New York
go see it shaggy taco shaggy taco does
sound like a sex position CEO so gonna
have again the earth alright good
afternoon
USO Vincent oh they're looking for
drake's fortune got it who Bruce
Campbell for Sully that would be great
although it feels like Bruce Campbell
has already played Sully and Burn Notice
yes this would be who julie bowen maybe
you've never played on charity Corvis up
uh i don't know if we play all of them
here I'll probably continue playing this
on my personal stream but I'd like to
play different games every single week
oh you hope take out the Spanish Armada
Gingras says Wow Larry again Francis
Drake was not an astronaut he was a
nautical not not not there's a Seinfeld
now why why was Drake good why was Drake
the man which is pretty impressive I
wanted to take him more than a week I'd
say probably probably a couple this
guy's just gonna talk all day got that
gun
nope not listening not listening at all
actually there haven't been any new
videos in the YouTube channel because we
were awful we were off last week well
there was a new video we put up Ron
Funches I like to watch
that's right starting tomorrow
know one thing they never have in these
I'm dirt really dirty all of a sudden
all that running and that guy's not
dirty at all why am i so dirty I don't
know if I wear jeans I feel like I don't
want to wear like some nice like
loose-fitting linen pants you know
something's gonna block the mosquitoes
but also blegh breathe a little bit it's
not Audrey Drake gram hoody takes a
better rapper Nathan Drake or Aubrey
Aubrey Drake gram you probably rap he's
got more adventures to talk about than
like rolling through the six with his
woes you know yeah I'm a Drake kind of
Drake the rapper only kind of has one
bit he's really sad he's the softest
rapper in the game Nathan Drake da has a
lot of bits he's got a gun he's actually
Drake probably has a gun also you know
I'm saying but he's not like he's not
held down by his woes he keeps his woes
in check Nathan Drake does Oh God look
at this he's like those donors arms look
weirdly long when I do that what look
his arms are longer than they should be
yeah like it's the same length of just
leg yeah that's interesting well I can't
get up here - although I think this was
remastered right all right let's see how
we're using a one boom mic put together
by well Becton over here in the corner
does this game have the journal I don't
know what that is pieces of tofu yeah it
might have been I don't know did you
write about his personal stuff like oh
so lonely I think we're supposed to be
over here somewhere
this guy's gonna beat us the right away
are you leaving us the right way bro do
a lot of jumping you to play tomb raider
we have played super yeah it was really
fun one of our favorites yeah yeah
absolutely this feels like they
definitely the Tomb Raider people were
like hey we want to make an uncharted
game right is this the way I should be
going
nope is there what if I do this what if
I do this nope nope nope no Matt well
let's keep walking
oh you know what maybe I have to jump
over from there to there probably right
yes I have John I have played game we
played a lot of games with team coca
fans last not last week two weeks ago we
played Mario maker that people in
people's Maps and we played what have we
played before we played rocket League
with people we played battlefront
battlefront hard law or not battlefront
battlefield hardline whoa hey thanks
don't worry I'll just do all the
dangerous stuff
whoa nice catch bro
by the way impossible to do in real life
oh wait I said I wanted to do this thing
do you know how much finger strength it
would take to do this so much yeah it's
us yeah exactly cross the way this one
perfect love that when I fall down it
was special guest Aaron Blair yeah yeah
there's nothing special about this guy
aside from my stunning good looks and
ability to make Beth feel uncomfortable
at any time wait what see told you be a
little bit tougher to do like a Mario
maker version of this game yeah just
moths everywhere all right let's see
you're trying to get up and get that
flashing thing we're not sure what it is
Conan is not in Armenia anymore
nope he's back he's back also weirdly we
flew in and out of Dubai which was crazy
that was another crazy experience
devised a very beautiful place oh Jesus
Blair if I can pull it together dude is
your clock back or you still feel weird
no I feel crazy it's an 11 hour time
difference from Armenia so I feel
totally weird yeah my brain is mush it's
like you ever leave a bunch of graham
crackers and milk that's exactly what my
brain is right now if you are dipping
graham crackers in milk right yeah and
and the doorbell rings and you go to the
door and it's someone selling something
right like selling him I can't jump over
there that's not the way to go and you
forget about the graham crackers because
this vacuum they're selling is just
amazing it's like one of those Dyson
ball vacuum Zoar it goes in any
direction and and then you kind of
forget about it and then let go then the
phone rings you're like ah man you got
to call your mom and now you're talking
to your mom for like an hour because
what you know like cousins being a real
jerk and then yeah and then later on
then it's like oh my god I got to make
that movie I already bought tickets to
it and you go on you see jobs in Steve
Jobs movie because you love Fassbender
so you guys see him it's pretty good and
then you get into a metaphysical
discussion about Aaron Sorkin and studio
60 on the Sunset Strip and whether or
not it deserve the the praise slash yeah
and then you come back and now you
realize you grab the graham crackers in
buckets but like six hours
yeah exactly I feel that do you stream
to Larry again says why not what's your
problem what do you think you're better
than us I wouldn't I would you know what
I would stream if there was a way to
stream a Game Boy Color there is I think
are we gonna be flashlights we push the
rock now see here's the thing in games I
hate using flashlights because I think
it makes you a target even if like in
The Last of Us it doesn't make you a
target I feel like a target and so it
affects my morale so then I play worse
you know look at this
can't stop can't stop can't stop the
rock video game councils yes Kruk soul
is saying he can they can help you set
that up yeah come to house look at this
bowl you could put guacamole in it I
think that's a helmet Drake Jesus oh
this guy is totally gonna betray us
right that's totally gonna happen
this guy's gonna screw us over you can
see of it hey Taiwan Steve thanks for
joining us
let's see you I call this video game
Council tall order what do you mean you
like yeah and they went by Robert's
Rules of Order exactly yeah yeah exactly
Parliament Funkadelic this guy's gonna
screw us over right we're all we all
know that's gonna happen don't trust
anybody with that many guayaberas
yet
we're pushing this or something push
something yeah no [ __ ] dude whoa I love
like we're just destroying like these
monuments we're like doing terrible
things that was like millions of years
old there are thousands at least and
we're just like eyelids blowed up
thank God they left exploding barrel
right there oh yeah you played far cry
for a lie yeah the man pit man pit why
aren't we trying to read as explores any
of like the the ancient language on
these walls yeah why don't you do
something
jerkface ah such a beautiful I'm not
gonna say anything about Sully's that
played all the games exactly I know he
betrays us I'm sure he does that's
obvious
he's anybody any character says I'm up
to my eyeballs in debt by the way yeah
anyone with money troubles is going to
betray oh yeah exactly yeah yeah yeah
let's hire the desperate guy to go on us
on our adventure for fortune would ya
hey let's lock ourselves in a giant oh
here we go oh let's whoa we're looking
at his journals brassiere a giant
brassiere all right
when I go foraging in the jungle I like
to bring up a cigar Elsa is there a new
one I don't think so somebody just
mentioned it on YouTube Catholic boys
are browsers exactly we got a light
browsers up Wow these old uh Aztecs
really love their porn they put browsers
everywhere what are we doing we have to
light this on fire should we like push
it over and burn up everything I think
that's what we're supposed to do now
let's light a fire in an enclosed space
a lot of wood there is a new Far Cry
jeez this Far Cry guys really pumping it
out this game must have been one of
those five-year turnaround game totally
yeah must have been really just like our
hopscotching wait where can we knock
this Pam what Lance oh oh here we go
more fire let's do it nope trying
ah there we go
oh that's fire burnt out rather quickly
with all the dry wood just kindling yeah
just burned enough to save us oh cool
I'm dead
stink salad yes sure what about churros
just like for churros yeah some street
meat well what should they eat for lunch
[Music]
okie was good before you died I'm dead I
died
dead died yes Bobo
Candyman we have that we have done
multiplayer games and we will do
multiplayer games again what should we
play next week is the question that that
one game where you couldn't you like
everybody was invisible
like one guy knew where everybody else
was but oh yeah the mario was really fun
it was really fun yeah we played that
with undateable last week we cast him
undatable who were awesome and ron
funches made a lot of those Mario maker
boards oh yeah punches and so anything
in here nope well I've destroyed another
precious artifact for no reason this guy
just going around just [ __ ] on like
the Aztecs these guys come from the you
have to you can't make an omelet without
breaking a few yeah or all the a let's
make an omelet but then ruin every
single egg yo Sully get you butt down
here Sully
oh wait went back in the thing wait what
take that priceless artifact yeah this
should just be called artifact killer
well she will show those things that
have survived for thousands of years
who's boss just remount your friends oh
I've seen Mount your friend oh I'd seen
Mount your friends see what do we do
here broforce a lot of bros okay bro hey
bro what is a 4pc don't say peace all
right we need to get the fire from up
there to down here how do we do it
why doesn't Sully get his ass down here
and help us out no souls will help souls
love salt huh huh can I just lift this
up somehow is there any kind of just
like a tiny there's like the big stone
door and then just like right next to
there's a tiny little door with a handle
I'll go up the ladder why is anything
yeah shoot at the middle thing that
helps the ladder I don't see a ladder
the ladders in the water room your mom's
in the water room no high five that damn
Jesus I can't expect Beth to high-five
me after a sweet your mom joke where's
his ladder at hearing so much about
hearing all about this ladder my mom
apparently yeah well your mom was in the
water room didn't make any sense still
the high five me have you gotten a
laptop girl license plate yes Oh
Beth you gotta just take out the vault
yeah personal brand get on that oh wait
there we go when in doubt blow something
up and destroy somewhere artifacts wow
that was cool
oh there are you guys are nighter oh I'm
so sorry Shirley it's behind the tree
thank you yeah I did oh I hate air and
blaze back great your mom my mom's in
the stream you know you could have just
thrown down the matchbook Sully I don't
mean to be a dick about this but you
don't need to come down yourself oh and
then then we will both wouldn't be
trapped in here so that should put us
that shady fridge makes a good point
you should put aside out of your laptop
that says my name is Beth I'm a person
yeah take mom is here yeah yeah yep
now what another puzzle laptop girl
would be a good Lawnmower Man sequel
laptop girl yeah she's no power she's
very sad it's in my little journal oh
boy
let's see
got it one two three four okay so what
square thing Pro square it profile thing
okay go back and see what he's so yeah I
just I was just looking at that so first
one is a square thing yeah yeah I got it
I got it stop telling me to look at the
journal I got it I have to shoot it or
something yeah gotta push dad what are
you doing we just shoot things now
no those dumb shouldn't have done that
[Music]
I do like that this the sound design is
fun in this game that's a lot of skulls
by the way does anyone ever think hey
maybe I shouldn't come down here whoops
how that was this one shoot everything
as one YouTube suggestion yeah wait I
did that wrong I want to go over shoot
yeah shoot everything Drake's revenge on
everything wait this is not the way I
want to do this are these other symbols
that yo one of my other symbols it okay
great I did catch on to that thing a
weird spot yeah here's the thing um I
already screw us look in your diary the
thing is this is the wrong stupid order
I don't know where the other two things
are is my question you know I know that
I know the order I'm supposed to do it
I want to this isn't it this is dumb
this is okay stop looking at that oh oh
I see how it's over there is that the
first one yeah the first one all right
diamond yeah no thank you jumpy you're
gonna have bad knees nasal yeah all
right here we go this one
all right Sully you're killing me Sully
you're killing me
all right what's the next one I got a
doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo this
guy's fingers have to be ripped up not
that one wait it's the profile one it's
not that's the third one do we dress up
at the office for Halloween we uh I have
is that an answer to your question it's
allowed it's allowed it's not
discouraged I don't know I do a thing
where this looks like the next one right
no this isn't the next one yeah
I every year I go the day before
Halloween
to the Halloween shop and I get whatever
costume fits me yeah so last year I went
as a giraffe but then I also got foam
abs so I went as a draft a sexy giraffe
would you go out last year oh I was a
hot dog oh yeah you're a hot dog yeah I
gave you a my birthday
well would you guys last year following
last Halloween Jesus Christ that's a
good ever since I had a kid yeah she
chose my what my Halloween costumes
gonna be this year oh nice Flynn Rider
from tangled whoa nice I love it
I love it I asked her what I should be
maybe I should be a better Olaf probably
start over
hey rare to see you later thanks for
joining us okay I got one up I think
this is just gonna be frustrating for
everyone involved no no I
I just have to do it the right order I
just can't get away from you Sully
there's no help do better creepy I know
I just need to stop doing so bad yeah
I'm just trying to be less shitty story
of my life that could be on my tombstone
still trying to be less shitty
I nailed it all right it's this number
two this is number two all right
number three is where number three is
over here love it so far it gives you
it's very satisfying this game the
puzzles aren't that difficult there's a
fair amount of action Sulli we all know
is going to betray us at some point
because he's got serious debts yeah I've
never played this game before heard a
lot of good things but never played it
so far it's great
I mean we're this is ten minutes into
the very first Uncharted so yeah Oh
remissness toads a great movie jump in
Sully oh that's right you're useless
literature to the repeated a other
sureties right yeah yeah yeah he sure
does repeat today sorry Tara not but I
wore this shirt because tonight is the
Star Wars trailer in Monday Night
Football they're gonna it's a new Star
Wars trailer oh they're playing it
during the broadcast during the
broadcast between the two games yeah
yeah so it's gonna be awesome
really I just died oh yeah
so that's why I can't wait for the new
Star Wars movie even though I'm not
gonna watch the trailer because I put a
moratorium on me looking at all new Star
Wars stuff I saw the poster backs and I
got pissed cuz I saw that something on
the poster I was upset about I don't
want to mention on the stream I'm not
angry
you look at the poster I'm not gonna
spoil it you look at the upper right at
the poster there's something there which
spoils it for me that's right Annabeth
is how googling like what that's right
you're right I'm very unhappy guys we're
only going 20 more minutes today because
this Thursday WW 2 times WWE Divas
Champion Paige is coming by to bring us
an exclusive look at WWE
- I'm sorry wwe2k16 a preview of that
awesome game we're gonna play with her
I'm very very excited I guess I'm
guessing she could murder me with one
punch
right she's probably ripped this is what
I'm talking about what just forget it
let's talk about it off the street do it
live all right where am I going do I
have to go down to this pit I didn't say
anything
I would never spoil anything no no how
does this work
I can't see daddy explore I had charted
lands on about uncharted flavors try to
do Doritos savage jerky this channel
sponsored by Doritos I wish this channel
was sponsored by Doritos yeah oh my god
Cheetos Doritos pizza rolls one of my
other favorite things pancakes can you
just get sponsored by a type of food
yeah
can we should get sponsored by yeah by
pancakes I guess I hop good sponsor us
alright where are we going here oh
that's what I've done for my last two
birthdays has made people eat at the
Hobbit menu with me it's been fantastic
it's true it makes me sad well always
have the Hobbit menu in our hearts and
there's a Denny's near me that serves
little bottles of wine little Hobbit
size yeah it's pretty great so I'm
guessing you have to shoot something at
this point right is this the point I
wish we shoot something what happens
here so I'm talking about pieces of tofu
this is exactly what I'm talking about
exactly what I'm talking about our few
questions yeah yeah exactly because I'm
becoming a pancake alright here we go
use the ladder carefully was there a
ladder that I'm not seeing there's a
ladder in the hole there's a ladder in
the hole she said oh there is oh there
it is all right there's a ladder
how do I
I don't think oh there we go
oh there we go got it although it is
water I could just I couldn't just fall
down into water
he's voice-activated yellow ladder yeah
it's voice-activated oh this seems bad
but your skulls on a chain I feel like
I'm gonna die in this room basically
right yeah I guess this is the point oh
here we go
let's get those skull chains working
I need more skull chains in my house we
should get some of those for the office
even if you walk in welcome to Team Coco
this is also feels very Goonies asked
yeah all right so I see we're filling up
the pit full of water
what for reasons poison water what's not
poison water
haha poison water my ass depending on
what I've eaten poison water Chooch a
chain chain of skills exactly well well
well
talk dirty to me Nathan Drake I do love
adventure games where you can kind of
just button mash I mean there there is a
certain amount of button mashing to this
which is good which I enjoy this is
normal because the chat wanted at normal
and I've died about 50 times oh I think
I can I see some exploding let's I think
I have some exploding to do how's that
for open whoo just destroyed a bunch of
archaeological writing so don't worry
about it just so you could come through
Sully old fogey hey let's just show you
some more stuff perfect nothing in there
so glad I ruined it world's a safer
place yeah I'm just good at just
destroying stuff
Wow that opened oh very cinematically
all right let's go yeah I wonderful have
to burn it nice bootcut jeans bro
oh ah let's run oh no I died oh no I
died oh I died I died here we go let's
go this looks safe don't say it again oh
he didn't thank God because I'm gonna
die about fifty times I don't need to
say this looks safe fifty times here we
go
all the way they turn it around on you
so you have to run this is you don't
know what's coming yeah it's very
disorienting oh my god I died I died
death number five Gingrich is keeping
track here we go let's try for six who
wants to die six times he wants to die
six times six times six times here we go
here we go let's do it let's do it let's
do it let's do it
oh no no no no I died I died
you just want ragdoll by the way boy
potato running apart from Crash
Bandicoot yeah what part is that I never
play Crash Bandicoot here we go oh no oh
no no no no no
how silly gonna get across is my
question
but not silly guaranteed there's just
gonna be like an easier way acrost yes I
knew it I knew it
screw you Sully you suck man Sully f off
he's the worst
I can fly
yeah screw Suleyman hashtag out for
silly alright well Sully why don't you
just figure out the right way to go here
let's shoot it tell them Wow no one's
ever seen this before
hammer hammer break break Mayan calender
re-explained yeah yeah who knew rosetta
stone shoot at you and shoot it what's
crazy actually is there's only one
rosetta stone if we never found those oh
so we never know Egyptian hieroglyphs
isn't that crazy to think about there's
only one that's insane without the
rosetta stone we'd have no idea weird
and then they turned it into a whole
series of translation things there never
be rosetta stone learn Italian in 20
days
so fashionably late basically that's
right these eyes are marginally less
dead yeah ooh what tracks are these come
on Sully I understand what made these
tracks something dragged through the and
I get to destroy priceless artifacts
let's just keep running until it tells
us to do something hey monkey tom 47
what's up thank you for joining us Oh
got it got it
oh it's from The Lion King wait is that
a giant submarine today's hey Bob eyes
in that that's like Lion King right yeah
kind of yeah vaguely the same thing
David
ignoring dialog and asking what happened
exactly okay in 7777 says we should
change our title I see love it what your
title is here's yeah why is there a
German u-boat here
don't give it to sully he's gonna betray
us he's got credit card debt he'll just
sell it
he's putting it out yeah he's putting it
on eBay a surprising fine everybody say
u-boat I guess so u-boat we boat we all
vote for u-boat
so it's not a little Raiders ish as far
yeah like the Hitler occult position
definitely feels like it can I
yeah it feels maybe like a little little
Raiders in terms of like except with
Spaniards instead of I want to go
underneath the water no I am a slow
swimmer
Belloc Shh Belloc somewhere yeah exactly
yeah yeah there's just hanging out guys
what's up oh you just swing on some
vines
whoa a new tomb raider heavily
influenced by this game
they're like Scully's arguing yes
Kelly's like sorry got a no-reserve
auction going on
he's the water they called bet oh Sh
Belloc walk over here right now here we
go sorry I just wasn't shocked her me
not doing something right shocker
oh cool thing is with this game I do
here's one thing I'm liking about this
game already I don't even know really
where to go but it kind of leads you
there in a great way
thanks I'm not gonna respond to you
because I'm holding off one hand you did
good that kind of put it on Rails and a
subtle yeah right does it feel like it's
on Rails but it's definitely on Rails
that said if you just keep hitting X
long enough you'll eventually kind of
get it like in this light look at that
that's pretty
Oh games were influenced by Prince of
Persia yeah you're right
oh man I played so much Prince of Persia
pretty immersion was a really fun game
because I'm of the imum pretty big
sucker for time travel stuff and that
was a fun game the way it all kind of
fit together was really fun and Prince
of Persia had a really fun combat system
Prince of Persia I have a lot of great
things to say about Prince of Persia
unfortunately none of them I have to say
about the live-action Jake Gyllenhaal
who's not purchased in any way wait it's
all soup
sorry no blood it's all soup Jeff Ross
yeah Jennifer Ross where's the soup go
to soup
uh I hate Aaron bleh yes I will tell
Georgia solinsky's awesome now I'm
starting to think I hate our blade is
Georgia slansky ooh dolly says the new
Castlevania demo on Nintendo DS plates
like a side scroller Prince of Persia
who love to check it out this is fun
look at this look at all these buttons
let's just start pushing buttons
it's button mash in real life oh don't
touch him you'll get sick I said don't
touch him dude what does I want to heal
dead bodies Yemeni oh well don't tell
Sully
ooh chocolate coins the treasure that
keeps on giving
I hope you've got some Purell or
something dude you just touch like a
decomposing me Jesus got the super flu
from a dead Nazi in a u-boat stranded on
a giant waterfall yeah
see if this was real life that would
just be rusted shut and we'd have to go
back yep
well that's it see you later wd-40 did
not fit in the carry
yeah exactly dad no catskin oil or
anything
seems like being a real-life adventure
it'd be exhausting it's so much easier
to just Netflix and chill you know I
like to explore these subcategories of
Netflix I'm like Nathan Drake when it
comes to exploring bad Netflix movies
non-stop kittens no it's the Apple it's
a notoriously bad really it's the
longest unwashed thing on my Netflix
queue oh my god I have to watch it bad
you got it yeah you got to get in the
right headspace book Sully's got debts
man twitch and chill ooh ninja now we're
talking dude Nathan Drake needs gloves
I'm not a germaphobe but this is
freaking me out like oh it matches this
menu I got it in an out burger yeah
what's up future killcam 87 love that
name ashley silly i think you will
believe this all right oh here comes the
deception that guy's face is Gnarls
Barkley
we better get something out of this trip
you know I heard though that they
wouldn't carry it in theaters which is
hilarious cause it only helps Netflix
yeah oh no that's bad that's very bad
get out of here
we gotta go we gotta get out oh no
Belloc sky already looks like i'm gonna
go is Gabriel Roman for Halloween and
I'm Gabriel rubbish do you think anyone
would get it if I want to give her a
Roman really excited one person would
get it yeah one person yeah hopefully be
a lady
it wouldn't be Gabriel Roman
Sully how do you what do you owe money
to this guy for oh look at the bags
under his eyes I have to say the acting
is great like the the mocap looks great
it doesn't and this is the first one
which is kind of Awesome please blow up
I want to you about to blow up
yeah blow it up blow it up
what does it mean it's just a placement
has distraught is 48 a little Botox
we'll get that ounces brother dad we
don't need a reminder nope he's so cool
[Music]
Oh what wait how is silly gonna betray
us yeah how Sully's supposed to betray
he's dead
oh my god holy crap whoa awesome
whoa my god I'm dead guys I think that's
gonna do it for today what a place to
end what a cliffhanger but that's what
uncharted is all about cliffhanger today
we've been playing the Nathan Drake
collection which smells amazing the
Nathan Drake collection uncharted it's
out now I believe go grab it now and
please make sure you turn in this
Thursday we're gonna welcome two-time
WWE Divas Champion Paige who's gonna be
bringing WWE 2k16 for us to play before
it comes out on October 27th so that
will be this Thursday at 3:30 right here
stream Cocco twitch.tv slash team Coco
and youtube.com slash Team Coco thank
you guys for joining us and we'll see
you on Thursday bye
[Music]
you